this is Michael Bryce time an executive
protection agent I've extracted my
client clean up is required you might
want to call the bomb squad
make it the fire department it's not my
call I'm afraid so
have a seat it's been a long day the
trial continues one of the world's most
brutal dictators
where the key witness to testify I can
assure you my mother plant running so
for that assault Kincaid is dead you'll
be paid there's a safe house I have a
job for you the transport is in there
what Duff 27 times that's how many times
this [ __ ] tried to kill me 27 28 you
all last one hour without me don't be a
little [ __ ]
tell us where your husband is you lost
my husband that is your job [ __ ]
anyway Bryson King hey don't make it to
pick you each other first
if you would mind the gun
okay country 1 my bad your bad know what
life gives you [ __ ]
you make cool a life doesn't usually
give you [ __ ] and then turn into a
beverage transport is in there
that blood
[Applause]
[Music]
how long I've been waiting like this
I'm not gonna look
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa let's talk about this
your job is to protect the most
dangerous man on the planet
27 times that's how many times tried to
kill me
[Laughter]
I'll be safe Romo
first-first the hit man's body guard
radar in theatres August 18th
[Music]
[Applause]
go with God
this man's killed over 150 people 250
easy I go through doors first I check
see this clear I play a guy named
Michael Bryce he's an executive
protection agent I've extracted my
client you might want to call the bomb
squad
make it the fire department my job is to
protect hitmen 27 times
that's how many times tried to kill me
28 now he's insane he's dangerous it
brings a sense of gravitas to everything
he does my job is to keep you out of
harm's way
thank god you're here I don't know what
I would've done without Sam pushes those
buttons a lot in the unique way that
only Sam Jackson can
[Music]
taking audience is really going to be
excited to see these incredible action
sequences is electrifying
very unpredictable we take them on a
real adventure
[Music]
really what happened to seatbelt rule
duction can't afford that so I'm an
executive protection agent my job is to
keep you in harm's way from our last one
without me man
you're bad
I hope they kill him I really do so heed
Man's bodyguard read it are in theatres
August 18th camellia I want to tell you
that I'm sorry for everything it's all
my fault
these are better than that say to them
the trial continues one of the world's
most brutal dictators with a key witness
to testify an executive protection agent
my job is to keep you out of harm's way
one hour without me tell us where your
husband is you're worried about my
husband's safety
he's unkillable are you kidding me come
on how have you stayed alive this long
[Music]
but Man's bodyguard radar in theaters
August 18th
I'm an executive protection agent you're
the most wanted hitman in the world
it's my job to keep you alive
how'd that go hard to tell
poetry the hit man's Fatiha read it off
in theatres August 18th
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she sounds like she's gonna make a good
mother someday mrs. Kincaid
you need to tell us where your husband
is why the [ __ ] should I
that is your [ __ ] job [ __ ]
but obviously you suck at it baby it's
me Mary shank you take Dutch fries and
areas what are they gonna do beat me
with a clog
Travel the perfect shot [ __ ]
faces dick back each else on your body
that's really beautiful man
bring it on I'm a triple-a rated
executive protection agent you're the
most wanted man in the world my job is
to keep you out of harm's way you will
last one hour without [ __ ] you just
gonna find a more intelligent way
I don't they kill him I really do
there's got a handedly ruin to the word
[ __ ] I was up here
goddammit I will bust a cap in your head
if you ever said please Jesus Christ
really what happened to seat that room
[Music]
this guy single-handedly ruined my life
and there he goes again
neither one picking Kady my job is to
keep you out of harm's way
I am on your way Bryson engage on me -
Thank You each other at first
right I'm not here men's bodies our
window in theaters August 18th
[Music]